hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump calling the 900 billion
covet 19 relief package a disgrace
urging congress to increase the direct
payments to struggling americans
well several republican lawmakers say
the measure is too expensive
and will lead to higher taxes and
increased federal debt
chief economist of moody's analytics
mark sandy breaks down what the stimulus
package includes
and what he believes is the most
important part of the bill
and while online shopping may make it
easier to snag those last minute holiday
gifts
it may also make it easier for cyber
criminals to gain access to your
personal information
fox news technology reporter brett
larson shares tips
on how to protect yourself and your data
plus commentary from fox news
contributor
and co-host of the five juan williams
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm dana perrino i'm brian kilmeade i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday december 23rd 2020
i'm dave anthony more corona financial
aid is coming to americans to boost the
economy
while we wait for vaccines to work once
we're on the other side of the pandemic
i
i feel confident that we're going to be
off and running there's just a lot of
reasons to believe that
the economy is got a lot of juice that
it wants to unleash
i'm chris foster the holiday season is
always a big one for hackers and online
scam artists
and fox news technology reporter brett
larson says not only that
i think it's pretty safe to say at this
point somewhere out there
lurking on the internet is your name
your social security number with your
birth date and quite possibly your
current home address
and i'm juan williams i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it took seven months of partisan
bickering
but congress has finally approved more
covid financial relief
it's not too little too late it's
directly targeted at exactly what the
country needs
right now republican senate leader mitch
mcconnell and the president-elect
agrees it does provide vital relief
at a critical moment but to joe biden
it's a down payment
and addressing the crisis the crises
more than one that we're in
there's a lot more work to do now the
900 billion dollar package includes
direct payments to most of us plus
extended and extra unemployment benefits
more ppp
loans to help small businesses and
housing assistance money for education
and vaccine distribution most lawmakers
in both parties approved but not
gop senator rand paul if money really
grew on trees
why not give more free money why not
give it out all the time well democratic
senate leader chuck schumer thinks more
money does need to go out we're going to
need a bigger bolder bill
and try to do it first thing when joe
biden becomes president so january
february
we will start this says consumer
confidence wanes says kovid surges
i think it's good enough to forestall a
double dip recession i i think if
lawmakers hadn't signed on the bottom
line
here the economy would have gone back
into recession early in 2021 so
i think we've avoided that mark zandy is
chief economist for moody's analytics
i do think the economy is going to
continue to struggle
until the pandemic starts to fade away
and on that front things look
a little bit more worrisome at the
moment than
than they did just a week or two ago so
i think we've
got a lot of a lot of things a lot of
script to be written here
what is it in the last two weeks is it
the renewed restrictions
with the surge of kova yeah i i
i think the pandemic is intensifying and
i do worry about the new strain of virus
in the uk
uh it is uh much more contagious and uh
you know logic would dictate you know
based on
the experience with this uh that we've
had so far that it's not going to be
contained
that you know likely will come here and
that means even more infections more
hospitalizations and more deaths it's
not it's not more virulent so the
mortality rate
doesn't appear to be any different
that's good news but
the fact that more people are going to
get infected and hospitalized that'll do
damage to the economy and
you know the hospital systems across the
country are already
operating pretty much a full tilt and so
i think
local officials are going to be under
extraordinary pressure to restrict
activity so we're going to see more
lockdowns across the country so i i do
think this is something we need to be
worried about
all right so there are a lot of things
in this stimulus package
there's direct payments there's the
extended unemployment with three hundred
dollars a week in extra benefits
of those two what's more important to
you the ui benefits are critical
uh these are we have lots of unemployed
americans
uh 20 million unemployed americans that
uh have no other source of uh income and
they rely
uh are relying very heavily on those
checks and without
this piece of legislation uh all that
money would go away
uh by the end of this year in the next
couple of weeks and so
the uh extension of the uh
emergency unemployment insurance and the
300 extra
a plus up in in a weekly plus up in the
payment
i think is is very very important uh
there were the result these are smaller
things but also very important were the
was the rental eviction uh fund
assistance rental assistance fund to
avoid to try to forestall evictions on
people there's uh uh about 10 million
uh renters out there that aren't making
their rent payments because they can't
and are
subject to eviction and this will help
with those folks i think that
smaller in the grand scheme scheme of
things but uh also very important
the last time this went through in the
spring
the extra unemployment was six hundred
dollars a week now we're down to three
hundred
is it better or worse this one
well i would i would have gone with the
six hundred dollars a week i i know
there's a lot of
uh debate around whether uh the six
hundred dollars
would result in disincentives to work
that people
would decide uh not to work even if they
had the opportunity to because of the
600 a week would cause their income to
be higher than they would otherwise if
they were working
but there's actually been a lot of good
research uh
done since the 600 week expired
and there's really no evidence that had
any meaningful
impact on uh people's incentives to work
i mean i'm sure there are examples
but from a broad economic perspective
no real evidence and i do think the
financial stress out there is
very significant i mean the census
bureau runs a survey
they've been doing it since the pandemic
began almost weekly or bi-weekly
and they asked folks what uh
you know where they're getting their
income their their funds to
just you know pay bills yeah and
increasingly you can see the stress i
mean almost 10 percent of the
respondents are now on food stamps
up from you know one or two percent back
at the start of the pandemic so
they just get in they're drawing down
any resources they had their bar
increasingly borrowing from friends and
family so i think the stress out there
is very significant so i
you know if i were king for the day i
would have gone for the 600 a week but
but you know
300 i think is uh uh is is enough again
to
forestall a you know a dark scenario for
the economy
now to these direct payments the extra
unemployment the amount
is half what was in the spring financial
aid package
instead of twelve hundred dollars per
person it's six hundred
twice that for married couples and six
hundred bucks per child but
not everyone will get that it phases out
based on income
starting at 75 000 a year if you earn
100k or more you get nothing
double that for couples house speaker
nancy pelosi wishes it was more money
but calls these payments significance
the president may insist on having his
name on the check
but make no mistake those checks are
from
the american people back to republican
senator rand paul
he told fox what could be dumber
as an idea to print up money we don't
have or
borrow it from foreign countries or
borrow from whoever we have to borrow it
from
and give it to people who are still
working mark zandy
isn't a big fan either yeah it's not my
favorite
way to help uh households i mean i i
think it
as you point out it's not well targeted
and that a fair amount of the cash the
money is going to go to households that
aren't under a lot of financial stress
that's why the ui the unemployment
insurance is i think much more
effective because it's directly targeted
to the people you who you know
need the help and i do think we we have
some experience here
there was a first round of stimulus
checks back uh march april may
as part of the cares act and we did see
a large share of that money
get just sitting people's checking
accounts you know they're saving it
and they're they're not using it so it's
not the most efficacious form of support
to the economy i mean if i
had to make a choice i i probably would
have taken the money
from the stimulus checks and used that
to provide help to state and local
governments because if they don't get
help they have no choice but to cut jobs
and
programs and services that are critical
to the economy so
i i would have made it a different
choice here yeah and i know there are a
lot of stories of cities that are
uh dealing with that issue right now
they've had to lay off some workers
don't have the money to bring them back
or don't have money
for a new police or fire class for the
2021
yet it's a political football because on
the right there are republicans who say
that some
states have been poorly run or some
cities poorly run
into deficit by too much spending
for liberal programs and democrats have
done a bad job fiscally and now we're
bailing them out with this money
that's the argument from the right and
that's why it wasn't in this bill
because it was one of those things that
couldn't get passed yeah it's not a red
or
or blue state problem i mean if you look
across the country
in fact the states that are struggling
the most are states
that are typically you know republican
dominated so i i
you know i'm just really hard-pressed to
understand that i mean in fact if you
look at
overall state and local government
spending in aggregate
and look at it relative to the size of
the economy say gdp
it's it's no higher today in fact it's
lower today than it's been on
average over the past 50 60 years so
it's
really difficult to make that argument
again there are examples i mean the
state of illinois
is a poster child for bad fiscal
management and
i agree you know you don't want to
reward that it doesn't make any sense
but
broadly speaking no and there's
really strong evidence from the
financial crisis and other recessions
that
providing support to the state local
government so that they don't have to
cut
teachers and fire and police and
emergency responders and health care
workers
is really very effective in helping the
out the economy
all right let's get into the other thing
that wasn't in this package because
democrats
were not happy with it that was the
republican push for
liability protection in this crisis from
people suing
companies and such what do you think of
that and do you think that kind of
protection is needed
yeah i'm sympathetic to providing some
uh some
uh some uh protections to businesses i
mean you know you got to be very careful
uh to you know balance the uh
the rights of people who've been wronged
uh so that they can
be compensated if they're uh
inappropriately treated
but i i do think the
the pandemic has created some very
unusual circumstances
and we don't want to end up after the
pandemic
in just a flood of suits and uh
litigation
and it just will delay the the ability
of the economy
to recover so i think you know some
form of of liability protection is
probably a good idea
2021 we have more vaccinations
we also have a change in presidents
joe biden will take over in january
in your estimation as an economist what
does it mean
what happens in your view when you
change from one party to the other party
has that typically been a big factor in
the economy
no it hasn't uh usually policies
with large economic consequences you
know play out over longer periods of
time
and just to switch over from one
administration to the next doesn't
uh isn't a big deal uh those changes
have
those big changes take take place over
or extended periods
this may be a little uh different though
because the policies
that uh president biden will pursue are
very different than the ones
president trump will but there are
things that he can do administratively
that will be very different than
president trump around trade for example
you know i think he'll still be very
forceful and engage the chinese but with
other trading partners i think he's
going to
uh he's going to eliminate those higher
tariffs that president trump put in and
normalize relationships but in the grand
scheme of things
you know no this isn't going to change
things that significantly
all right so 2021's economy is based
more on how well we can get out of this
pandemic then
right once we're on the other side of
the pandemic i i feel
confident that we're going to be off and
running there's just a lot of reasons to
believe that
the economy is uh got a lot of juice
that it wants to unleash
and we'll get a lot more a lot more
growth i mean there's certainly going to
be
problems we're going to work through
over a longer period of time and
you know there's going to be a long tail
to this pandemic but i do think on the
other side
on the other side of this we should get
going mark zandy chief economist moody's
analytics thanks for joining us and
happy holidays happy new year to you
thanks dave you too i hope you have a
great holiday thank you
[Music]
this is juan williams with your fox news
commentary
coming up 2020 has been a big year for
fraud
the federal trade commission is
reporting record losses to social media
scams
its operation income illusion has been
cracking down on false promises of money
or jobs going after dozens of operators
of those schemes
and the holidays are the most wonderful
time of year for scam artists trying to
rip us off
especially now during the coronavirus
pandemic with more people than ever
browsing and doing their christmas
shopping online
this this is always the time of year
when scams go
up brett larson's an anchor on fox news
headlines 24 7 on siriusxm and a
technology reporter on fox news channel
and fox business network
it's the holidays people are shopping
online um
you're probably shopping at stores you
may not have shopped at during the year
so you're getting a lot of emails about
the orders
and when you add to that the whole
coronavirus
and the hacks and uh
things happening around that from the
near duels on the internets
uh it's it's going to be an interesting
several weeks to see
uh what happens well you mentioned for
example email receipts
the thing about these scams is that
they're really cheap and simple to set
up
and if you send everybody if you just
send everybody an email that looks like
it came from target a good percentage or
walmart or whatever it is a good
percentage of your recipients are going
to have shop there
yeah they're going to say oh geez i did
i did order something i better click on
this oh it's a problem with my order i
better click on this etcetera right
and it's it's the easiest scam to carry
out this time of year for that very
reason you're you're a lot of all of us
are going to be shopping online this
year
because we're all hunkered down in our
homes because of the pandemic
and the the reality is you know fedex
isn't gonna email you and say there's a
problem with your order click here and
give us your credit card information
that that's not gonna happen
so you have to pay close attention and
you're absolutely right
these hackers don't have to be extra
careful and you know cross their t's and
dot their eyes on these kinds of emails
because if you send out right now
an email to a thousand people that says
your walmart order has been delayed
click here so we can fix it
there's almost a guarantee that at least
100 people are going to click on the
link in that email even though it's
totally bogus because
a lot of people may not have even
shopped
at walmart or target or costco
but they may see the email and think
well i did buy something online maybe
maybe this is it you know a lot of times
when you buy things on amazon you're
buying it from
maybe a small business somewhere it's
that's going to be shipped by them you
know amazon's handling the transaction
but you're not gonna get that kind of
email so the best thing to do if you're
shopping online
keep a list of everything and every
place that you've ordered hang on to
those receipts
and then if you get a suspicious email
from a vendor
don't click on the link in the email go
to the website where you went to place
that order go to
etsy go to walmart go to target.com and
log into your account and see if there's
any alerts there because if it's true
it's gonna be there unless it's just
perfect
the replication of the email and the
website you go to whatever there's not
much you can do there but what are some
really obvious sloppy things that people
should be looking at
there's often typos in these emails uh
the grammar is wrong
spelling can be incorrect uh the
the graphics may not look right you know
companies that do these mass email
marketing campaigns
they put a lot of energy into making
sure whether you
open that email on your mobile device or
you open it on your computer or you open
it on your tablet
that it looks right for your screen that
takes a lot of work
and a lot of work means more money and
more effort into something and if it's a
scam
you're not gonna put that level of
effort into it so the email's gonna look
a little wonky
um so so pay attention to that pay
attention like i mentioned to the the
typos and the the spelling mistakes
and then if you hover your mouse over a
link
which you can do on your computer you
can tap and hold it on a
on a mobile device without actually
opening the page you're gonna see where
that link is actually taking you so if
it's not
taking you to walmart.com if it's taking
you to say
you know order inquiry dot risvex
dot ca dot whatever like that's a focus
a bogus address flicking through
instagram facebook whatever every now
and then you see stuff
not every now and then every day you see
stuff advertised that's meant oh yeah
for you that's meant for you most of
them
perfectly legitimate so a lot of this a
lot of the stuff
to use a cliche if it looks too good to
be true it is that's
that stuff's never coming to you that
that
that that 50 thing that you see on a
facebook ad that
should be 500
you're just gonna give somebody a fight
you're just giving somebody 50 bucks
yeah you know we saw this so much
uh during the ongoing covet pandemic
because
people were looking for specific things
people looking for hand sanitizer people
are looking for face masks
people were looking for you know toilet
paper and soap you know in some
instances well
a lot of very savvy hackers got in on
that uh
i actually saw an ad that came in
came into my instagram feed looked
totally legit they had a website
the website looked legit the website was
able to take my credit card information
and place my order and i got charged for
it and
nothing showed up and that that's
actually happening a lot because the
barrier to entry
to put an advertisement on facebook and
instagram
is pretty low you can do it all online
you don't have to interface with a
person
you need very little information in
terms of
what your business is you know you need
a website you need the ability to take
credit cards well that's something you
can get from godaddy for a few hundred
dollars and
you're good to go you're going to make
that money back if you process
you know 10 fraudulent uh orders at 30
bucks apiece well there's 300 bucks and
you made some money
so definitely when you're scrolling
through
facebook and and instagram and twitter
when you when you see those ads like you
said if it looks too good to be true
it ain't happening we're also seeing
this with the playstation 5 which is
selling out it's you know once again
it's a hugely
popular device to get people want it
under the christmas tree they want their
kids to have it for the holiday season
and that is
inevitably turns into an opportunity for
scammers to get your money uh for people
to resell it to you
for two or three times its value uh
there are folks who are selling
access to these shopping bots so you can
pay
50 bucks to have access to this shopping
bot that will then go out and try and
buy you
a playstation i mean it's there's the
higher a demand
goes for a product the more you're going
to see scams like that so
you have to be very aware of where
you're shopping online and
and how much things cost
uh you mentioned coronavirus for a
minute uh i suppose we're also going to
have to worry now
about um scams
people are desperately want who may
desperately want a vaccine or
desperately need money
or need a job um so there are a lot of
vulnerable people there who might be
seeing what they want to see in terms of
um in terms of offers yeah i'm hopeful
and i'm certain this will happen i'm
hopeful that
you know the government comes out and
sets some very clear guidelines
on on how this will work so that scams
like this are going to be a little
harder
to undertake but you still have to be
extra careful
uh around these big issues i mean these
are these are
social engineering hackers now that's
what all of this stuff is they they take
advantage
of the news story of the day the the
news
trend of the week the news trend of the
last year they take advantage of all
that stuff
and and they know where the needle is
going in terms of
the opinion of people that they're
reaching out to so they know people are
anxious about not having a job they know
people are nervous about getting a
vaccine
and they're going to take advantage of
that if you have been taken advantage of
financially or or they got your they got
your personal information is it better
is it easier now
to be made whole or if or if somebody's
got your
uh personal information to impersonate
you or are you still just as hard off as
you were maybe
whatever 10 15 years ago when this stuff
was really becoming prevalent
you know is it is it easier to deal with
yeah
at this point i think it's it's gotten a
little bit easier to deal with
because at this point all of us have
been compromised
between those massive hacks that we saw
over the last few years with
you know the tens of millions of credit
card numbers that were stolen from
target or or home depot or nate you know
insert retail
giant retailer and you know follow up
with the with the hack we've seen so
many of those
with the equifax breach i think it's
pretty safe to say at this point
somewhere out there lurking on the
internet is your name your social
security number with your birth date and
quite possibly your current home address
you have to be unfortunately because of
that you have to be extra
vigilant you have to pay attention to
your base bank statements
you have to pull your credit report as
often as you can
set up alert monitoring so if somebody
tries to open a credit card account with
your information
you're going to be alerted to that lock
down your credit account if you can
when you're purchasing online always
always always use a credit card
if you don't like using credit cards if
you instead use a debit card make sure
you have purchase protection
talk to your bank find out what kind
what you're on the hook for if somebody
gets your debit card because
your debit card is connected directly to
your bank account if somebody pulls
400 off of it that goes away from you
right away at least with your credit
card
or when you use a credit card if
somebody fraudulently uses it you can
call the credit card company and say
that wasn't me and for at least while
they investigate
you're not going to be on the hook for
the charge and hopefully obviously
they'll come out the other end and say
you know what you're right we've we've
had several fraudulent charges to this
company and
we're going to go ahead and reverse that
for you fred larson fox news headlines
24 7 on sirius xm
does some technology reporting on fox
business network fox news channel brett
merry christmas happy new year buddy
merry christmas happy new year to you
chris nice chatting with you
[Music]
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
juan williams
what's on your mind earlier this month i
tested
positive for the coronavirus i'm a 66
year old cancer survivor
i'm a black man and i inhale my share of
second-hand smoke
because my wife smokes cigarettes so
i set off several red lights that
indicate a high risk
of a bad outcome if i got cobit 19
and i really didn't want my wife the
smoker to have
a covert 19 attacking her lungs
after the phone call telling me i tested
positive on a lab test
i was sent for two more tests they
confirmed the worst
yes a bad situation kept going down
when i called home my wife told me i
couldn't come home for fear of spreading
the virus to her
so i immediately went into quarantine in
a hotel room
i gotta tell you physically i was not
doing well already there was extreme
fatigue
sudden waves of fever and then chills
that left goosebumps on my skin
the headaches the sinus pain feeling as
if i was going to pass out
it was terrible at night sleep was rare
dreams they were out of control i'd turn
over and think this bed is
wet then i'd realize there was sweat
pouring off of me
but it was the isolation that was
hellish that
and feeling caught in an out of control
situation
the doctors you know they tell you
there's not much
they can do for you when you have
coronavirus
until you can't breathe if you have
trouble breathing they say
call an ambulance the text and the
emails from friends
in my moment of such grave fear became a
lifeline
so many people helped me push back the
fear
my son left me novels my daughter left a
folding exercise bike so i could keep
moving
even better my daughter brought my
grandchildren to the street far below my
hotel room window
they waved at me the hotel staff left
food outside my door
despite the kindness my mind started to
wander into some dark places
i can't sugarcoat it i was going a
little star crazy
sick as i was i found myself telling a
friend to look out for my family
if the virus overwhelmed me and you
start asking yourself
where did i get this what did i do wrong
it's only speculation but the biggest
risk i took was one cold night when i
got pulled into a crowded new york
restaurant
a few days after that i reached out to a
doctor but he told me not to worry
even my nose started dripping i told
myself
yeah don't be a wimp it's allergy season
the seasons are changing
and people do get colds but you know it
got worse
and then came the positive test three
days into quarantine my wife called to
say
she tested positive then my guilt kicked
in
but the doctor said since we both had
the virus now we could quarantine
together
i could go home finally ending the
isolation was a big emotional lift
now several weeks after my positive test
and my quarantine
i'm feeling much better my wife is even
better
thank god over the years i've rarely
shared personal stories
listeners come here to hear about the
theater of politics
my general rule is to only open personal
wounds
when there's a clear lesson to offer the
lesson here is to take this virus
seriously
wear the mask wash your hands keep your
social distance
and reach out to people who've been hit
with it especially
at this time of year the coronavirus
doesn't care whether you're a liberal or
conservative
we're all in this together our best hope
is to take care
of each other merry christmas
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information on your time
listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes